that's who I think mad things look bad
am I really this dutiful guy called the
devil I have a weird persona for here Oh
Nellie think about it
hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba and I'm
John listen if you guys want to see a
funny intro go to our first reaction for
this teaser didn't think that we should
do one because I just remember that as
we started recording anywho the official
trailer for Marvel's daredevil season 3
has dropped I have never felt more
prepared for anything Marvel related in
my life I finished the born-again
graphic novel about a week ago or
something like that man loved the hell
out of that graphic novel I cannot wait
to see how loosely based this season is
so excited for that anywho before we hop
into things I want to say thank you to
everyone who's been following us in the
Stardust app as of this morning we
reached 7,000 followers on there it's
not a sponsor shout out just shouting
out because we do post daily on there
for a 30-second reactions for any film
TV show or trailer and I specifically
wanted to mention it because I started
watching Iron Fist a couple days ago and
made it to only episode two so far but
I'm actually really enjoying it and I'm
posting a reaction for every episode
that I watch so if you want to keep
updated on you know sort of things that
is much more than just Iron Fist over
there yeah go ahead and follow us guys
anywho let's watch this trailer
I used to listen to people asking for
help but that serious race trying to do
is help people
I'm fooling myself darkness was so
darkness
haha I'm daredevil
oh [ __ ] he's got rats on everyone Hey
[Music]
precision why did you say I want to make
a deal No
he's claiming to change weight to stop
[Music]
[Music]
black-on-black
sometimes you have to hook one person to
the greater good
oh dear devil
[Music]
oh yeah and in the comics they do hire
someone to pose as daredevil it's it's
pretty brief in the born-again graphic
novel but I don't think it's gonna be
the same character that they used in the
comic book my eye I'm guessing that they
hired bullseye to actually pose as him
because there was an Instagram post that
revealed that bull's eye was in this
season because of Charlie Cox his
personal trainer doing awesome things
and that's just my guess it might be the
same character from the keyboard again
graphic novel it's Colin Farrell it's
fallen for Alfred yeah they brought him
back for this but yeah that makes sense
why he has the black suit on is there
someone going around posing in the
actual suit oh dude it is great it's
like a harrowing season it's the exact
season I want to be mad all the amounts
of crazy action that's gonna go down in
this season it's all backed by the
emotional intensity all the action seems
plot driven as opposed to just like good
that was an issue I kind of have a
season two at one point we're halfway
through so much fighting going on but I
don't really care about most of it it
seems like every single fight scene here
is gonna be so important like this looks
like a testament to just the build-up
they've done over time because Wilson
Fisk is such a great villain for any you
know movie whatever and to see them yeah
going off such dark paths is headed
right towards each other like I'm really
excited to get into this season as much
as I was joking about this you know
being very loosely based on the graphic
novel there's so much here that is so in
tune with the graphic novel in terms of
Matt Murdock is clearly gonna lose
everything they've certainly made that
clear you kind of get that hints at that
I think even more so in that moment
where he's like chewing on the toothpick
he has a hat on and he's having one of
those conversations where he's not
letting everyone know Matt Murdock's in
the room key things to decide they're
having that conversation where they're
talking forward but they can't be seen
talking directly to one another having
to do it has to be done yeah one of
those moments and you get clearer images
of sister Maggie his mom in this trailer
and the the influence that she plays on
him after he's lost everything at the
dynamics in the intense rivalry between
Wilson Fisk and Matt Murdock not just
daredevil but Matt Murdock oh yeah I'm
really wondering how Wilson Fisk though
after everything is able to come into
the spotlight again and be a powerful
influence but then I think about our
politics I will make the video about
that we're doing a tremendous amount of
work in space I said maybe we need a new
force we'll go with the space force like
it's not that far-fetched now that I
think about it I mean they're going with
that angle of like he cuts a deal with
the FBI so he's at least out in the
public maybe you know confined maybe
very restricted maybe having to operate
in a clandestine kind of fashion using
his you know skills as a manipulator so
it's not like he's like fully free but
yeah yeah I mean especially given the
current climate I wouldn't put it past
him to be able to be out in the public
yeah you know producing these
machinations you know relatively simply
I guess it was fun to try to pick apart
if like I'm not gonna do it now but on
my own time it's gonna be fun to pick a
party go okay this seems in the red
costume is that part Matt Murdock yeah
there's that the other bad Daredevils do
from like the last episode yeah Italy
comes back in full force because that
church fight looks really scary and
intense and it makes me flashback to the
daredevil movie actually because there's
the fight scene in there you know it's
like it's even jacket Upchurch people or
and is that the attack that are talking
about if that's the case that's a very
personal way to go after Matt Murdock
yes because that's not Murdock's you
know that he's Catholic I think that's
the church it was too big part of his
life yeah so to actually go and attack
the church in daredevil form that would
be a major insult to Matt Murdock is
yeah and I mean with with that trope
specifically I gotta imagine we're gonna
see a number of shots where it's like
you know maybe the intro to an episode
or maybe like cutting directly into it
so at first you're like oh is this Matt
and then yeah slowly you realize oh god
no it's not yeah well it seems like he's
gonna be doing two things he's gonna be
tearing down Matt Murdock and he's gonna
be framing daredevil yeah just oh man
such an intense season ya know not
prepared for how I'm gonna be so on I
mean just that shot where Wilson Fisk is
looking at a bunch of different media
news outlets all playing at once because
he has ADHD or something I know that to
me feels so out of the born-again
graphic novel I don't exactly know what
room this is but there is there is the
moments like that in the comic book
where he has like multiple screens on at
once and just watching [ __ ] unfold and
watching his plan fall into place and
he's just like eating it up you know and
when you're finished type in your name I
wouldn't put a bathroom to have
something like that just like up in his
penthouse or wherever he's relegated to
now he's out and back in the semi back
in the world it seems like a lot of the
themes of what this season's gonna be
dealing with is gonna be Matt Murdock
losing everything and because of that
how dark is he gonna go every trailer
we've seen has been about like that
every single one seems to be going down
and as far as like the comic when he
does become like a loon he doesn't
become a monster he's cut off from his
friends to write like they think he's
dead right I think at the beginning of
this season they think he said but he's
in like lawyer outfit throughout so he
has to come back into the public maybe
not like a big showcase the way I would
be for even kingpin coming back at it in
the public eye but his friends would
probably find his live he starts up his
law firm and that's when Wilson Fisk's
starts taking them down and what I mean
though is when a guy loses everything
like that and with the kind of person
Matt Murdock is when every season
including defenders is always about am i
bad guy yeah every every season is him
dealing with this like complex my
villain I just be the devil of Hell's
Kitchen I would like this show to push
him into the darkest depths possible
without him becoming a full-on villain
but to at least tease us into the
territory of is he gonna come a bad guy
is he gonna have like one moment where
he just goes too far
yeah like Luke Cage season two
I don't want to spoil anything that goes
on in that season but the way things
play out they do that very well with
Luke Cage but I think daredevil has even
more of a potential to embrace that
element of becoming a bag because you
never feel that in the comic but I think
you'll be cool for the show to push that
oh yeah definitely and you know here's
hoping that we get some more of those
juicy courtroom scene yeah there's just
something so excited about watching him
fight those prisoners dude nobody does a
hallway fight like Darren oh hey but no
without the mask yeah you know just in a
suit when you see Charlie Cox is so
well-trained I imagine that this would
be technically its fourth season because
he's in every episode of the defenders
so this way he learned from Finn Jones
all right yeah series like I live up to
this yeah yeah but no in all honesty
Finn Jones is much better this time
around these are for season two well
yeah this is watching that fight man I
could not be more excited you know
there's something kind of fitting for
this for it to be on October thing and
that's not a horror show but you know
it's got such darkness in there that it
fits in the hall and it's called
daredevil you don't want to have your
version of getting spooky is just
feeling dark inside feeling the weight
of human ugliness then this is a perfect
horror show forgiveness all right guys
well how excited are you for daredevil
season 3 I have I'm not sure if we're
gonna do patreon reactions for this
really covering so much over there but
at least for sure come around the star
does that you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell and yeah down life follows and star
those people place